bonsoir à tous
on va commencer
merci beaucoup à tout et à tous d'être
d'être présent très nombreux pour cette
pour cette conférence dont cambou deux
filles avec madame bateau et monsieur
jancovici sur les blocages de la
transition écologique
donc un premier mot déjà pour remercier
l'ensemble de l'équipe de l'association
de l'école d'affaires publiques de
sciences po qui vous propose cette
conférence aujourd'hui
on vous invitant même bateau et monsieur
jancovici nous avons voulu proposer une
conférence qui puisse explorer vraiment
les blocages de la transition écologique
sans rechercher le clash ou le buzz
forcément et pourtant votre venue à
créer un vrai enthousiasme puisque cette
conférence est et diffusée en direct si
les problèmes techniques le permettent
à reims sur le campus de sciences po à
reims par l'association alternative mais
aussi dans plusieurs dîners à paris on a
reçu beaucoup de demandes de de
retransmission de la conférence pour des
dîners donc il faut croire que les
jeunes s'intéressent à leurs futurs et
et si ce soir nous allons explorer les
blocages de la transition écologique
nous allons aussi abordé quelques
solutions
donc monsieur jancovici vous êtes
ingénieur formé à l'école polytechnique
vous avez co fondé en 2007 le cabinet de
conseil carbone 4 qui accompagne les
entreprises dans leur transition
écologique et l'association de shift
project qui est un laboratoire d'idées
pour réduire la dépendance de notre
économie aux énergies fossiles vous
n'êtes pas par ailleurs membre du haut
conseil pour le climat
et delphine batho vous avez été ministre
de l'écologie en 2012 est actuellement
députée des deux sèvres et présidente du
parti génération écologie et vous avez
porté lors de votre campagne à
l'investiture du parti europe
ecologie-les verts pour la
présidentielle
l'idée de la décroissance comme solution
à nos crises écologiques vous êtes aussi
conseillère spéciale de la campagne
présidentielle de yens de yannick jadot
donc merci à vous d'être d'être présent
ce soir pour un détail un peu plus
pratique on demande de rappeler que le
port du masque est bien obligatoire dans
le dans l'amphithéâtre et la conférence
va donc s'organiser en trois temps une
intervention préliminaire des deux
intervenants un échange entre vous et
puis il y aura des questions de la salle
il ya des micros qui sont installés dans
les travées il suffira juste de se lever
de faire là de faire la queue derrière
et vous pourrez poser votre question
merci
bonjour à toutes et à tous alors pour
entrer dans le vif du sujet jean marc
jancovici vous êtes pour une transition
énergétique et écologique qui passe en
partie par une le renouvellement du parc
nucléaire et
et pour regarder sa part dans votre dans
le mix énergétique français alors je
vous laisserai nuancé et développer tout
à l'heure mais il faut créer le débat
madame delphine batho vous êtes pour une
sortie progressive du nucléaire au
profit des aînés des énergies
renouvelables mais pourtant l'un comme
l'autre eh bien vous partagez une vraie
volonté de réussir la transition
écologique et énergétique et plusieurs
de vos analyses notamment sur sur la
décroissance se rejoignent
vous affirmez que le mode de décision
politique actuelle mais aussi sont ces
décisions qui consiste le plus souvent à
investir dans les nouvelles technologies
pour réussir la croissance verte ne sont
pas suffisantes et la transition
écologique énergétique doit
s'accompagner d'une modification des
comportements des citoyens et des usages
que nous faisons de l'énergie drc usages
se confronte à des réalités physiques
immuable qui pressent la décision
politique comme le pic de pétrole la
diminution alarmante des ressources et
aussi leur exploitation toujours plus
croissante alors de nombreuses questions
se posent et on sera un plaisir de les
aborder ce soir avec vous vous dénoncez
tous les deux donc déblocage de
gouvernance
qui s'appuie sur des indicateurs
économiques
pour qu'ils s'appuient toujours sur la
croissance comme le produit intérieur
brut et qui ignorent les les aspects
environnementaux et l'impact social du
changement climatique et donc comment
élucider ce contraste entre la réalité
physique de la planète et la décision
politique qui est parfois décalé très
souvent consensuelle et et pratiquement
déconnectée de ses réalités physiques et
bien j'ai hâte de vous entendre parler
sur ces questions et je vous remercie de
nouveau de bien d'avoir accepté notre
invitation je vous laisse la parole
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas si ces micro 1,6 c'est bon là
vous m'entendez je parle comme ça
je suis assis toute la journée dont j'en
ai marre d'être ainsi alors on sait
subdiviser le travail avec delphine donc
moi je vais vous parler du problème et
de la solution comme ça moi ça va aller
beaucoup plus vite et aura beaucoup plus
de travail que moi il faut que j'ai eu
le plaisir de faire dans cet amphi même
une conférence de rentrée alors comme je
suis vieux je ne sais plus s'il ya un an
il ya deux ans il ya trois ans ça devait
il ya deux ans je crois ou trois ans les
plus brefs
qui est disponible sur un réseau social
que je ne nommerai pas dans la vidéo
donc ce que je vais vous présenter ce
soir est un petit badge est il faut que
je fais maintenant un métier qui offre
un grand privilège puisque les vieux
radote c'est de la physique étant
immuable j'ai le privilège de pouvoir
raconter sur la même chose donc je vous
racontais toujours la même chose au
moins un apéritif
donc je vais vous parler de transition
alors transition en général enfin en
tout cas dans le métier qui est le mien
ses associés beaucoup aux questions
d'énergie et de climat énergie et comme
dans toute bonne dissertation on va
commencer par parler du premier de ces
deux termes énergie et climat transition
écologique ça va au delà de ça d'une
manière générale c'est la confrontation
aux limites planétaires mais il se
trouve que quand on regarde bien
l'énergie est un très bon proxy de la
confrontation à l'ensemble des limites
planétaires et on va voir pourquoi alors
il ya plein de manières de rentrer dans
le débat sur l'énergie
il y en a un qui est particulièrement
d'actualité en ce moment comme vous le
savez probablement qui concerne son prix
donc dès que vous avez un prix de
l'électricité ou du gaz qui augmente un
peu trop c'est le branle bas de combat
au gouvernement ce qui est très
exactement en train de se passer en ce
moment envoyé par exemple le prix de
l'électricité augmentent et le prix du
gaz augmente et mathieu castex besoin de
s'exprimer le prix du pétrole augmente
et à ce moment ça remue un peu alors
je ne fais pas du tout ça parce que
votre directeur est un ancien de la sncf
mais je vais vous j'ai essayé de vous
expliquer pourquoi en fait c'est une
manière très très imparfaite d'aborder
le problème donc prenons cette belle
entreprise dans lequel votre directeur a
traîné ses guêtres avant de venir ici
la sncf tirs des trains ça ne vous aura
pas échappé de temps en temps des bus ça
s'appelle keolis alors pour ça il ya
besoin de gens qui travaillent à la sncf
et quand vous regardez les gens qui
travaillent ce qu'il représente dans les
postes de dépenses de la sncf c'est à
peu près la moitié
ce qui explique pourquoi de temps en
temps on essaie que ce soit un peu moins
à ce moment ils se mettent en grève on a
également besoin d'énergie il se trouve
que la sncf qui est le premier
consommateur d'électricité de france
c'est la première entreprise
dans les entreprises premier
consommateur d'électricité c'est
probablement un des premiers
consommateurs de carburant une partie
des ter fonctionne au diesel
sans même parler de la filiale keolis
qui fait fonctionner des bus est tous à
7 3% seulement alors maintenant
imaginons que la sncf veuille diminuer
ses charges de 3% option à elle prend
des gens et les met à la porte jusqu'à
ce qu'elle ait baissé de 3% ses coûts
alors comme la masse salariale c'est 50%
de ses coups ça veut dire qu'elle
licencie 6% de ses effectifs grosses
grèves etc enfin 6% de ses effectifs ya
toujours une sncf derrière c'est
peut-être pâti marche autant de trains
qu'avant mai 2007 ses terres
si elle supprime 3% de ces charges sous
forme de ses achats d'énergie il n'y a
plus un train qui avancent plus un bus
qui avance à plus de sncf donc regarder
ce que coûte l'énergie est une très
mauvaise manière de rentrer dans le
débat parce que ça masque totalement la
dépendance du fonctionnement de la
société à cette chose très particulière
une autre manière de rentrer dans le
débat c'est de dire qu'il faut
l'économiser alors manifestement on n'a
pas bien écouté les slogans de l'ademe
parce que si vous regardez la quantité
d'énergie utilisée par l'humanité depuis
un siècle et demi oui manifestement ça
ressemble pas bien à une économie ce que
je suis en train de vous montrer c'est
plutôt plus y en a plus on en consomme
et en faites ce que vous pouvez voir sur
ce graphique qui vous retrace les
énergies utilisées par l'humanité depuis
un siècle et demi c'est que jusqu'à
maintenant il n'y a eu aucune
substitution à large échelle toutes les
énergies que nous avons mobilisé se sont
empilées les unes sur les autres on
utilisait du bois on a rajouté du
charbon par dessus on a rajouté du
pétrole par dessus on a rajouté du gaz
par dessus etc et l'éolien et le solaire
ne font pas exception à la règle on lui
rajoute par dessus au niveau mondial ça
ne substitue rien à large échelle pour
le moment
alors ce qui est très intéressant
également c'est de voir que toutes les
innovations techniques auxquelles ma
corporation peu de temps en temps vous
renvoyer en 10 ans grâce à tel ou tel
type de progrès ça va aller mieux en
fait on se rend compte qu aucune des
innovations techniques mises en oeuvre
jusqu'à maintenant n'a permis
d'infléchir cette tendance c'est à dire
que ça n'a absolument pas ralenti la
hausse de l' de l'énergie qu'on utilise
d'envoyer il ya plus en plus de villes
il paraît que les urbains sont moins
consommateurs d'énergie que les ruraux
bar peut-être ça se voit pas là dessus
on a tertiarisée l'économie par avec
l'économie tertiarisé et moins gourmande
en énergie que je sois pas vraiment là
dessus on a numérisé l'économie par
excès - groupe oui ça se voit pas
vraiment là dessus donc pour le moment à
chaque fois que l'on dit il ya une
innovation technique qui a permis
d'aller dans le bon sens jusqu'à
maintenant ça n'allait pas bien en fait
vous vous rendez compte que
macroscopiquement ça n'est pas exact
voilà et là vous pouvez voir un autre
une autre chose sur laquelle j'attire
votre attention c'est évidemment c'est
une petite pique pour vos anciens qui
sont rentrés dans le journalisme
il n'y a jamais le moindre rapport entre
la pagination d'un sujet dans le journal
et son importance réelle dans le monde
donc je répète pour ce qu'on peut bien
entendu il n'y a jamais le moindre
rapport entre l'importance réelle d'un
sujet dans le monde et sa pagination en
journal
par exemple ce qui fait patiner
l'économie européenne depuis 2008 c'est
le stress que nous avons déjà sur les
combustibles fossiles ça n'est jamais
dans le journal j'avais par contre le
transfert de messi ça oui donc y'a voilà
il n'y a pas de lien entre ce qui a dans
le journal et l'importance réelle de
quelque chose dans le monde
l'essentiel de l'énergie qui est
aujourd'hui mobilisée par l'humanité
c'est des combustibles fossiles ce qu'on
appelle également des combustibles
carbonées parce que c'est des résidus de
vie ancienne d'où le nom fossiles
c'était 80 % on part dans
l'approvisionnement mondial en 1974
c'est toujours 80% aujourd'hui donc ça
fait maintenant cinq ans tant que les
combustibles fossiles sont à 80% de
l'approvisionnement mondial un peu plus
un peu moins ça varie d'un ou deux pour
cent dans un sens ou dans l'autre mais
globalement c'est toujours à 80%
alors en ce qui concerne la france va
dire oui du reste ça n'a pas tardé dans
cette école de la polémique à sortir le
mot qui devait faire que l'on se tape
dessus savoir nucléaire alors petit
graphique que je vous proposerai vu le
coup venir donc je vous montre ce
graphique
la france est elle un pays tout
nucléaire vous avez ici l'énergie
utilisée en france en fonction de
l'endroit où se trouve la machine qui
utilise l'énergie donc si la machine
head et dans une usine c'est là si elle
sert à transporter des gens ou des
marchandises c'est là si elle est dans
un bureau c'est là et si elle est chez
vous c'est la cas ici et dans un champ
c'est là et pour chaque bar donc la
hauteur de la barre c'est la quantité
totale d'énergie immobilisé par les
machines du secteur et la couleur que
vous avez au sein de chaque bar dit où
vient où est ce que dans l'environnement
on a trouvé la source d'énergie qui
permet de faire fonctionner la machine
alors comme je suis taquin évidemment je
suis très taquin gmi nucléaire en verre
ici donc l'électricité d'origine
nucléaire elle est verte un tout petit
peu anticipé la taxonomie là vous avez
la biomasse là vous avez les autres
énergies et là maintenant je vais cercle
et les combustibles fossiles qu'on
utilise en france eh bien vous voyez que
la france est comme les autres pays
occidentaux un pays qui reste avant tout
fossile donc effectivement j'assume le
fait que je considère que le nucléaire
est une très bonne manière de faire de
l'électricité il n'empêche il n'empêche
notre pays est essentiellement un pays
dépendant des combustibles fossiles et
je peux vous assurer que si demain matin
y'a plus le pétrole vous mourrez tous de
faim et moi avec on est totalement
incapable d'approvisionner les villans
nourriture aujourd'hui 100 camions
totalement incapable donc la france est
un pays à dominante fossiles quand on
regarde d'où vient l'énergie qui permet
de faire tourner les machines exactement
alors pas dans les mêmes proportions des
à dominante facile quand même
dans le monde alors la france à une
exception aujourd'hui c'est que
l'essentiel de son électricité et
décarbonées notamment à cause du
nucléaire alors ça par contre c'est une
exception mondiale si vous regardez d'où
vient l'électricité dans le monde ce qui
est le graphique que je vous projette
maintenant eh bien vous voyez que la
première source de production électrique
dans le monde c'est le charbon suivi du
gaz suivi ensuite de l'hydroélectricité
non carbonées ensuite vous avez le
nucléaire ensuite vous avez l'éolien le
solaire et la biomasse et vous avez
également un peu de pétrole que vous que
vous voyez là 60 % d'électricité
mondiale est d'origine fossile hier on
brûle des combustibles fossiles dans des
grandes bouilloire compliqué ça permet
de faire de la chaleur de la vapeur
tourner une turbine tourner un
alternateur c'est ça la production
électrique et le charbon reste la
première source de loin d'électricité
dans le monde
donc on n'a pas vraiment économiser
autre chose que vous entendez évidemment
beaucoup et souvent c'est tout ça va
être bientôt un problème oubliés puisque
nous allons aller vers un monde
totalement renouvelable alors je ne sais
pas ce que vous verrez de votre vivant
ni moi du mien en ce qui concerne le
monde tout renouvelable par contre ce
dont je suis absolument certain c'est
qu'un monde sans qu'on s'en rende
ouvrables c'est possible ça ne pose
aucun problème en voici un exemple
non seulement c'est possible et ça ne
pose aucun problème mais c'est le monde
dans lequel nous avons vécu depuis
l'apparition de notre espèce jusqu'à ya
deux siècles donc c'est sûr que ça ne
pose aucun problème
il n'y a aucun problème à faire un monde
100 % renouvelable aucun
est ce que on peut faire un monde sans
qu'on s'en rende ouvrables avec 8
milliards d'individus sur terre aspirant
au niveau de vie d'un smicard france est
beaucoup moins évident que la réponse
soit oui et probablement que la réponse
est non
voilà donc en matière d'énergie il faut
toujours compter ne pas se contenter de
slogans peut pas sortir d'un débat sur
l'énergie sans avoir compté il faut
sortir la règle à calcul pour commencer
à avoir des conclusions opérationnelles
en fait le la bonne réponse en ce qui
concerne l'énergie et comme dans ce jeu
ses lèvres la réponse dès lors la
réponse des la voix si voix la l'énergie
c'est ça en fait l'énergie c'est la
nourriture de ce costume d'iron man et
d'iron man que vous portez en permanence
sur vous à nous dire non sur moi je ne
porte pas en permanence un costume
d'iron man je porte un pot leur sweat
shirt à jean des chaussures que vous
n'êtes pas du pied nu c'est pas du tout
un costume ainsi si vous emportez en
permanence sur vous comme moi comme nous
touche du reste sauf qu'il n'a pas la
tête d'un costume d'iron man il a cette
tête là en fait le costume d'iron man
que nous portons tous sur nous c'est
l'ensemble des machines existant à la
surface de la planète et c'est elle qui
sont mis en mouvement par l'énergie donc
en fait l'énergie c'est la nourriture
c'est les épinards de popeye et là en
l'occurrence c'est le pétrole le gaz le
charbon et marginalement le reste qui
met en mouvement toutes les machines que
nous avons sur terre et qui nous rendent
la vie si douce parce que c'est bien la
sa4r aujourd'hui elles nous rendent la
vie si douce donc en fait l'énergie
c'est des croquettes pour machines si
l'on veut
les machines en question si on fait un
petit calcul d'ordre de grandeur on se
rend compte que grâce à leur bibine
spéciales elles ont multiplié par deux
cents en moyenne mondiale la puissance
musculaire des hommes et des femmes
alors je vais vous le dire de deux ou
trois manières différentes ça veut dire
que s'il n'y avait pas à l'énergie donc
les machines sur terre pour avoir la
même production économique dans le monde
il faudrait multiplier la population
mondiale par 200 et déjà 8 milliards on
a un petit poème de place alors à 1600
milliards ça commencerait à devenir
vraiment compliqué je vais vous le dire
d'une autre manière s'il n'y avait pas
l'énergie donc les machines sur terre à
population constante pib mondial serait
divisé par deux sens
pour oublier les études à sciences po -
vous à suivre pib / 200 vous n'êtes pas
là je vais vous le dire encore autrement
ça veut dire que le mode de vie d'un
terrien moyens aujourd'hui
dans un monde sans machine lui
demanderais d'avoir 200 esclaves à sa
disposition h 24 365 jours par an et en
france on est plutôt à 6 ans et dans
cette salle vous êtes plutôt si s&p plus
on est plutôt habile
c'est ça votre mode de vie et le mien
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qui se
balade autour de 1000 équivalent
esclaves 1 grâce aux machines à vous
comprenez pourquoi c'est un peu une
drogue dure ce compliqué de son passé
et à cause du fait que c'est les
machines qui transforme l'environnement
est plutôt puisque nos muscles sont
devenus ridicules même ceux de charger
des guerres face à la puissance des
machines et bien il est normal que nous
ayons aujourd'hui ce que je vous montre
sur ce graphique qui n'est pas une
démonstration qui est une conclusion
fait comment dire qui est une
observation normal compte tenu du
rapport de 1 à 200 dont je vous ai parlé
avant il est normal que en première
approximation dans le monde la
production économique soit au premier
ordre une fonction linéaire de la
quantité d'énergie c'est-à-dire du parc
de machines en service
donc sur ce graphique où chaque année
représente un point en partant de 1965
pour elle jusqu'à 2020
j'ai mis en abscisse la quantité
d'énergie c'est-à-dire le parc de
machines en services et en ordonnée le
pib mondial eh bien vous voyez en gros
dis moi combien la planète consomme
d'énergie je te dirai quelle est sa
production économique normale encore une
fois c'est pas vous qui produisent et
l'acier celio fournit les laminoirs
c'est pas vous qui produisent et vos
vêtements c'est des plates formes
pétrolières des mâts des moissonneuses à
côte ont des machines à tisser des
machines à coudre etc c'est pas vous qui
produisent et vos aliments c'est même
pas les agriculteurs qui produisent des
aliments c'est des usines d'engrais des
tracteurs des moissonneuses batteuses
des camions et des chaînes fin de chaîne
frigorifique et les les machines à faire
le yaourt et la donne voilà c'est ça qui
produit les aliments c'est pas nous
c'est pas les agriculteurs d'accord donc
en fait c'est les machines qui
produisent absolument tout sur terre et
donc il est normal que au premier ordre
la production économique soit une
fonction linéaire de la production fait
de la quantité d'énergie mobilisés et
dont là vous comprenez tout de suite que
dans le monde dans lequel nous sommes
imaginez qu'on va diviser la quantité
d'énergie par 4a production économique
constante sarah besoin d'une
démonstration un peu plus solide que je
suis sûr qu'on va y arriver
et comme l'essentiel de l'énergie et
fossiles vous avez ici le drame des
négociations climat c'est que le pib
mondial est aussi au premier ordre une
fonction linéaire des émissions de co2
puisque l'essentiel de l'énergie fossile
ce qui est une autre manière de dire que
aujourd'hui résoudre le problème climat
sans décroissance personne n'a trouvé la
martingale
donc je dis pas qu'il faut de la
décroissance à ce stade je dis juste la
bonne nouvelle derrière si vous allez
voir façon on va pas y couper mais à ce
stade je vous dis juste une chose
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas faire encore
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas faire
donc les 19e et 20e siècles peuvent se
résumer d'une manière assez simple nous
avons sur terre tout un tas de
ressources dont des combustibles
fossiles dont je rappelle que dans la
convention économique ils sont gratuits
toutes les ressources naturelles sont
gratuites par convention dans
l'économique vous allez apprendre ou pas
de vrai je ne sais pas ici la convention
économique qu'on va vous enseigner les
prix n'intègre que des revenus main à
prix c'est un ensemble de revenus humain
de salaires et des rentes encore il n'y
a rien pour dame nature ou monsieur
nature je ne sais pas dans cette affaire
rien
et donc le pétrole est aussi gratuite le
vent mais beaucoup plus facile à
extraire de l'environnement que le vent
ces combustibles fossiles brûle donc
peuvent alimenter des machines qui vont
permettre de transformer toutes les
autres sources que nous avons sur terre
qui sont tout aussi gratuite dame nature
nous a donné gratuitement les mines de
fer les mines de cuivre les mines de
diamants mines de bauxite les océans les
vagues le vent les sols cultivables tout
ça c'est gratuit et on transforme ces
ressources pour en faire tout un tas
d'objets
en discutant l'autre jour avec le patron
de sedin culte de 10 millions de
références m'at-il dit donc aujourd'hui
on peut faire absolument tout et
n'importe quoi
y compris des brosses à dents qui font
paimpont grâce aux ressources et aux
combustibles fossiles
cette productivité des machines
absolument faramineuses a par ailleurs
totalement déformé la structure des
métiers alors ce soir j'ai pas le temps
de vous en parler mais en fait ce qui a
permis de tertiarisation totalité de
l'économie ce qui a permis de créer des
villes et de les nourrir etc c'est
l'énergie abondante en fait qu'il n'y
avait pas d'employé de bureau avant
l'époque de l'énergie abondante ça
n'existait pas vous aviez quelques
nobles qui avait un peu le temps de
s'asseoir et sinon et quelques employés
de l'état civil mais sinon c'était à peu
près tout donc en fait ce qui a
totalement urbanisées tertiarisée
mondialisée fait monter le pouvoir
d'achat etc c'est l'énergie abondante
tout ça c'est l'énergie abondante et ça
a transcendé les régimes politiques du
reste partout il ya eu de l'énergie
abondante quel que soit le régime
politique en place il ya eu à peu près
la même évolution en termes de
productivité économique deux structures
des métiers etc ça a été plus fort que
tout et on a l'habitude de compter ça
avec le pib mais c'est une vision très
partielle alors très rapidement j'ai
vous parler maintenant de deux limites
planétaires qui peuvent mettre une fin à
cette économie cornucopia ton ucopia qui
vient de la corne d'abondance
il ya un premier sujet qui est le
changement climatique je vais vous en
dira rapidement trois mots et un
deuxième sujet dont je vous rappelle que
le journal ne parle pas mais qui pour
autant est déjà à l'oeuvre en europe qui
est la contrainte amont sur
l'approvisionnement énergétique
on va commencer par parler de laval
alors laval on va rapidement parler des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et de
la hougue ils viennent aujourd'hui alors
sur ce petit camembert je vous ai des
composés l'origine des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre dans le monde et c'est
tout gaz à effet de serre inclut donc le
co2 le méthane le protoxyde d'azoté les
gaz fluorés voilà tout ça est un plus
20% des émissions planétaires viennent
des centrales à charbon
la moitié se trouve en chine donc des
vous acheter un truc made in china vous
acheter un truc made in charbon
le charbon c'est essentiellement
asiatiques
80% de la consommation de charbon
aujourd'hui se passe en asie
et
l'augmentation de la consommation de
charbon est essentiellement asiatiques
d'où la raison pour laquelle je pense
personnellement qu'il faut faire feu de
absolument tout bois pour dézinguer le
plus vite possible toutes les centrales
à charbon dans le monde nucléaire un
tout
8 % viennent des centrales à gaz et à
fuel essentiellement à gaz dans cette
affaire donc la production électrique à
charbon et à gaz c'est plus d'un quart
des émissions mondiales de gaz à effet
de serre 4% c'est les cimenteries là que
j'ai pas le temps de rentrer dans les
détails
après vous avez 12% c'est le reste de
l'industrie alors là dedans vous allez
trouver la syrie qui fait 4 vous allez
trouver le
la chimie qui fait 4 et après tout le
reste fait le reste le chauffage des
bâtiments fait 5 à 6 dans le monde alors
c'est pas beaucoup dans le monde c'est
beaucoup plus en france mais tous les
pays du monde ne sont pas tempéré 14%
ses les transports 6% pour les voitures
4 pour les camions 2 et 2 pour les
bateaux et les avions en ordre de
grandeur donc voyez tous les camions du
monde et toutes les cimenteries du monde
c'est un problème du même ordre de
grandeur
vous voyez que la totalité des
transports mondiaux c'est un problème
plus petits même s'il est important que
les seules centrales à charbon dans le
monde
vous voyez que les centrales à gaz c'est
plus important que les voitures dans le
monde
après vous avez 1 20% en gros qui sont
les émissions d'origine agricole là
dedans vous avez le méthane des
ruminants vous avez le méthane des
rizières le protoxyde d'azoté qui est à
l'épandage des engrais dans les champs
là vous avez deux drivers essentiel la
taille de la population la fraction de
produits carnés dans l'alimentation
enfin ou de produits d'origine animale
10% c'est la déforestation qui est un
processus amont de l'alimentation aux
coupes des forêts pour faire des
surfaces à vocation agricole alors c'est
à nous de l'alimentation ça peut être
aussi à monde l'énergie quand on fait
des agrocarburants et enfin 7 % c'est
des poudres de perlimpinpin diverses le
traitement des déchets
là dedans l'énergie fait une grosse
moitié entre 55 et 60% donc c'est un
gros paquet et ce n'est pas la totalité
donc quand on s'occupe de climat on peut
pas regarder juste énergie il ya
d'autres trucs à regarder également
quand on rajoute des gaz à effet de
serre dans l'atmosphère l'effet de ces
gaz c'est de pacifier l'atmosphère aux
infrarouges terrestre et donc ça va vous
augmenter la température déquilibre près
du sol alors ce graphique vous montre
qu'elle a été l'élève à sion de
températures passées de la planète
depuis 1 0 de référence qui est la
température du 19e siècle la deuxième
moitié du xixème siècle ça date de sa
part de 1950 vous voyez que l'essentiel
de l'élévation de la deuxième moitié du
xxème siècle c'est essentiellement le du
xxème siècle essentiellement sur la
deuxième moitié que ça c'est fait et
aujourd'hui on a gagné un peu plus d'un
degré par rapport à la température dite
pré industriels envoyez que quel que
soit le scénario qu'on suit à l'avenir
pendant les vingt ans qui viennent
l'élévation de température va se
comporter à peu près la même manière
c'est une autre manière de dire que le
changement climatique est un processus
qui a tellement d'inertie je pourrais
revenir s'il ya des questions qui au
moment où vous appuyer sur la [ __ ] de
frein la seule certitude que vous avez à
ce moment là c'est que la voiture
continue d'accélérer pendant 20 ans
avant qu'ils commencent à se passer
quelque chose
donc il ya une inertie absolument
considérable ça veut dire que il faudra
que vous ayez l'âge de vos professeurs
pour que si on commence à agir
maintenant vous commenciez à voir la
différence avec un monde dans lequel on
n'agit pas
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut rien faire
au contraire si vous me pardonnez cette
expression c'est à dire qu'il faut
sérieusement je pouvais le culte mais on
voit le résultat de cette affaire encore
une fois avec un énorme décalage donc ça
ça veut dire aussi que quoi qu'on fasse
sur la baisse des émissions il faut en
même temps se préparer à des dégâts
climatiques qui vont aller en augmentant
très rapidement falloir faire les deux
en même temps
alors est-ce que quelques degré
d'élévation dont on parle c'est quelque
chose de significatif ou pas ici vous
avez la manière dont la moyenne
planétaire a varié alors cette fois-ci
non pas sur un siècle et biner sur 10
bilan donc ici vous voyez il ya 8000 ans
en arrière fait huit mille ans avant la
naissance de monsieur jesus christ et la
l'époque contemporaine
eh bien vous voyez que la moyenne
planétaire sur ses dix mille ans elle a
varié d'une fraction de degré d'accord
une fraction de degrés avant elles
s'étaient réchauffées rapidement la
déglaciation c'est à dire le passage
d'un paysage qui ressemblait à ça en
france aux paysages que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui parce que c'est à peu près
ça dans le paysage français et bien
c'est 4 degré d'élévation de la moyenne
planétaire 4 à 5 par beaucoup moins 4 à
5 là vous avez ce qu'on a déjà fait au
20e siècle et là vous avez ce que nous
pourrions faire à l'avenir en continuant
d'acheter des smartphones fabriqués au
charbon
vous voyez bien qu'on est en train de
parler quelque chose d'une brutalité
absolument inouïe et dont l'essentiel
des conséquences
continuera à s'amplifier bien après
longtemps après qu'on ait réduit les
émissions à 0
longtemps après
alors quand on parle de changement
climatique on parle de température mais
pas que ici vous avez la manière dont
les précipitations vont évoluer et
pardon doit pas les prescriptions
l'humidité des sols va évoluer par
rapport à la situation dite pré
industrielle dans un monde qui se
réchauffe de 2,2 et bien ce que vous
voyez bonne nouvelle puisque c'est là
qu'on habite tout le pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen va sérieusement s'assécher
alors ça c'est pas bon pour les
écosystèmes et c'est pas bon pour
l'agriculture donc ça veut dire que
l'agriculture du pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen à souffrir en 2011 il ya
eu quelque chose qui ça faisait un peu
jeune pour avoir connu mais il ya eu un
ep un soulèvement dans les pays du
maghreb s'est appelé le printemps arabe
et puis il ya eu aussi un conflit qui
s'est déclenché dans un pays qui
s'appelle la syrie j'ai peut-être
entendu parler et bien dans l'est dans
ces deux cas de figure on peut relier ce
qui s'est passé à un déterminant enfin
il ya eu un élément conjoncturel
climatique qui est intervenu dans ces
événements évidemment c'est pas le sol
quand un vase déborde pour savoir si
c'est la première ou la dernière goutte
qui a fait déborder mais en l'occurrence
ça fait partie des gouttes qui ont fait
déborder le vase ce qui s'est passé sur
le sur le climat dans c'est à dire vous
voyez que dans des zones très habité
donc ici là l'europe les états unis une
bonne partie de la chine une bonne
partie de l'amérique du sud et notamment
tout le bassin amazonien pop bonne
nouvelle pour l'amazone l'afrique du sud
etc vous allez avoir des assèchements
alors même que vous aurez plus depuis
deux épisodes pluvieux intenses et donc
vous aurez des problèmes agricoles qui
vont augmenter dans un rapport du giec
qui est sorti il ya maintenant un an et
demi si ma mémoire est bonne ou deux ans
vous aviez ce graphique qui vous graduée
avec un code couleur l'ampleur des
conséquences pour un certain nombre de
10 thèmes là que vous avez en bas et le
code couleur c'est que tant que vous
êtes en jaune c'est local est à peu près
gérable et quand vous passez dans le
violet ça devient globale est ingérable
et bien ce que vous voyez c'est que pour
l'insécurité alimentaire à partir de
deux degrés de degré et demi on bascule
dans global et pas gérable
donc des migrations des conflits des
guerres des soulèvements des
déstabilisation politique des dictatures
malheureusement ce graphique nous dit
qu'on va risque de voir en arriver en
pagaille a donc sais pas s'il ya un
court dictature à sciences po pour le
mans mais c'était une option à
considérer
alors si on veut pas de toute cette de
toute cette affaire quel est le cadrage
de l'action ici vous avez donc il ya
deux droites importante dans ce que je
voulais raconter ce soir la première
c'est énergie économie et la deuxième
c'est émissions cumulées température
alors ici vous avez un graphique qui
vient du dernier rapport du giec et qui
vous dit comment est ce que la
température planétaire
réagit en élévation en fonction de la
quantité totale de co2 qu'on a mis dans
la poubelle atmosphérique on regarde la
quantité totale pas les émissions
annuelles tout ce qu'on a rajouté depuis
qu'on a commencé à émettre
alors à fin 2020 on avait émis à peu
près de 2300 milliards de tonnes de co2
et de fait la température moyenne
s'étaient réchauffées papa de pardon d'à
peu près un degré quelque chose à ce 1°
virgule 1 on a des vous avez déjà 15%
des coraux qui sont morts il ya déjà des
espèces en france des espèces d'arbres
qui sont plus ou moins condamné à un
degré vous avez déjà en 2000 jeu
puisqu'elle a listé 2019 je crois 40 %
en moins sur une récolte de patates
d'année voilà on a le dôme de chaleur au
canada et 50% en moins sur la récolte de
blé dur tous à 1,1 degré tous à 1,1
degré donc même les 1,5 que du reste on
va dépasser allègrement
ça va déjà être beaucoup plus
désagréable que ça sans parler des 2
degrés qu'on va probablement aussi
dépassé allègrement partie communale
alors si on veut tenir les 1,5 oui j'ai
fini d'entendre
ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on limite les
émissions planétaires à 3000 milliards
de tonnes dont 2300 déjà été visé ça
veut dire que compte tenu du fait que on
est aujourd'hui 8 9 milliards
d'individus ça veut dire qu'un bébé qui
naît aujourd'hui il a le droit sur sa
vie sur sa vie durant supposons qu'ils
n'aient 80 ans qu'il vit 80 ans pendant
il a le droit d'émettre un dixième en
ordre de grandeur de ce que ses
grands-parents ont émis leur vie durant
un dixième
1/10 corp à 10 % - 1 10e
si on veut se limiter à 2° bas même
motif même punition et là mon bébé il a
droit au sixième il est quand même
beaucoup mieux loti dans tous les cas de
figure ça veut dire qu'on est sur une
trajectoire où il faut un convive de
plus par an
ça veut dire quoi qu vite de plus par an
ça veut dire que les émissions doivent
baisser au moins d'un facteur 3 des pays
par delà d'autres alité par au moins
d'un facteur 3 entre maintenant et 2050
et ça ça veut dire qu'il faut baisser
les émissions de 5 % par an tous les ans
à partir de maintenant et 5 % c'est ce
qu'on a eu en 2020 à cause du donc il
faut un convive supplémentaire de plus
tous les ans encore si on veut régler le
problème climatique alors il se trouve
que l'épuisement des gisements de
pétrole va venir à notre secours et de
gaz aussi parce que le puits le pic de
production sur le pétrole conventionnel
est passée en 2008 voyez donc c'est
encore avant le printemps arabe
normalement vous en souvenez pas du tout
et si on regarde quelle est la
production future de pétrole voilà deux
graphiques celui-là est en avant
première donc ça c'est là en gros une
estimation haute de la quantité totale
de pétrole qui pourrait sortir des puits
à l'avenir mais en fait toute cette
partie moutarde là c'est l'énergie qu'on
utilise pour faire sortir de pétrole des
pulls donc vous devez défalquer ça pour
avoir l'énergie nette à disposition de
la société et vous voyez que la quantité
de pétrole à disposition de la société
dans ce graphique ne retrouve jamais son
niveau d'avant qu'ovide et c'est très
exactement ce que le chiffre project
avait publié il ya maintenant six mois
lui mois sur la quantité de pétrole
produite par les 16 premiers producteurs
qui exportent en europe tant rôle est
suspendu producteurs mondiaux au moins
le canada et le brésil
et on était arrivés à la même conclusion
c'est à dire que nous avons probablement
tout pétrole passé le pic et si on l'a
pas probablement passé c'est qu'il est
pour vraiment dans pas longtemps et vous
voyez que pour les cinq ou dix
prochaines années même si on se fiche du
climat au mieux c'est à peu près stable
avant un grand toboggan même si on se
fiche du climat comme de toute façon il
va y avoir significativement moins d'ici
à 2050 de pétrole pareil pour le gaz qui
va rentrer en europe et pareil pour le
charbon puisque ces énergies sont déjà
en baisse en europe est en baisse
significative donc là la fin de cette
intervention elle est pour vous dire
août que vous pouvez retrouver tout ça
dans cette excellente album que
nous avons un sujet avec le climat qui
ne se résout pas quand on arrête les
émissions nous avons un problème avec
l'économie parce qu'aujourd'hui elle est
dépendante mondialement des émissions de
co2 et mondialement de l'énergie fossile
et de toutes façons de l'énergie fossile
il ya un moment où on en aura de moins
en moins ce qui veut dire qu'une bonne
partie de la transition que nous allons
devoir faire nous allons devoir
d'affaires en décroissance
ça c'est ça le cahier des charges pour
l'avenir
je me rends
[Applaudissements]
c'est à vous madame bateau alors en plus
je vais rattraper le temps de parole de
capri jean-marc d'abord bon de soir à
reims et toutes celles et tous ceux qui
sont en train de dîner mais nous on est
très bien ici ensuite je vous demande
votre indulgence parce que je tiens une
saq pekhterev mais j'ai un test pcr
négatif mais donc je ne suis pas au
mieux de ma forme je vais donc essayer
d'aller à l'essentiel parce que moi j'ai
envie de pouvoir débattre avec avec vous
d'échangés de répondre aux questions il
ya peut-être deux remarques liminaires
que je voudrais faire la première c'est
que rien n'est possible sans faire le
bon diagnostic de la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes dans lequel ce dans
laquelle se trouve l'humanité etc
aujourd'hui encore malgré la quantité de
données et de connaissances
scientifiques accumulées depuis des
décennies et des décennies et des
décennies
le diagnostic est un terrain de bataille
et un terrain de combat parce qu'en fait
nous ne sommes pas seulement confronté à
[Musique]
un réchauffement climatique et à son
accélération on est on est confronté à
un processus global
qui est la dynamique de la grande
accélération qu'on pourrait appeler
aussi celle de la grande destruction de
l'entrepôt scène avec un effondrement
extrêmement rapide à une vitesse
foudroyante de la biodiversité une crise
des ressources est globalement un
dépassement des limites planétaires dès
9hoo ont selon compte limites
planétaires limites planétaires qui
définissent l'espace de sécurité dans
laquelle la vie humaine et les
civilisations humaines ont pu se
développer sur terre on est donc dans
une situation
d'urgence absolue à brève échéance quand
on prend
les données notamment sur le
réchauffement climatique
on est dans la décennie critique et donc
j'ai en moi j'en tire une première
conclusion en réaction votre votre
intitulé à votre questionnement c'est
qu'il faut mettre à la poubelle le mot
de transition
parce qu'en fait aujourd'hui on peut
discuter de son origine de la façon dont
il a été conçu au point de départ etc
mais aujourd'hui quand vous entendez
dans le débat public
en 2040 on va faire ceci en 2050 ce sera
comme cela et d'ailleurs on s'engage à
ceux ci à cela je vous conseille d'avoir
un petit warning allaire greenwashing
qui s'allument dans votre cerveau parce
qu'en fait la seule chose qui compte
désormais c'est ce que nous faisons dans
la décennie actuelle est ce que nous
faisons entre maintenant et 2030 dont
jean-marc a rappelé que toutes les
décisions qui sont prises aujourd'hui
auront des conséquences dans 20 ou 30
ans et au delà à cause de l'inertie
notamment du système du système
climatique si on prend en matière de
biodiversité
si vous voulez on est déjà à 80% des
populations d'insectes et un tiers des
populations d'oiseaux en moins en france
donc on est au delà même de la notion
d'urgence d'ailleurs on ne sait même
plus quels mots utiliser pour parler de
l'urgence donc à chaque nouveau rapport
du giec ont d'urgence absolue extrême
urgence absolue on ne sait plus comment
le dire et du coup il ya quelque chose
de trompeur dans le mot de transition
qui était valable il ya 20 ou 30 ans
quand on pouvait imaginer
vous voyez faire tourner le curseur pour
tendanciellement modifier la trajectoire
de la société là on est c'est comme si
on était dans un train qui fonce à toute
vitesse vers un mur et flo effectivement
négocié un virage mais la première chose
à faire c'est d'appuyer sur la [ __ ] de
frein on continue aujourd'hui d'appuyer
sur l'accélérateur donc ça c'est la
première première remarque que je
voulais faire
la deuxième c'est qu'en fait au lieu de
les blocages je voudrais parler de le
blocage
on peut dans le débat revenir sur toute
une série de dimension de ce qui empêche
la transformation ou le changement ou la
prise en compte réelle de l'urgence
écologique mais nous sommes en réalité
aujourd'hui dans une situation où on
compte on confond en fait les symptômes
c'est à dire les conséquences
on est dans des débats si vous voulez
sur le traitement des symptômes ou le
traitement des conséquences et non dans
un débat sur sur la cause
c'est-à-dire l'obsession pour la
croissance économique et une société un
monde qui tourne autour de cette idée du
toujours plus donc c'est un peu comme si
vous aviez une maladie du taf du
tabagisme que vous vouliez combattre en
prescrivant de continuer à consommer des
cigarettes quand on vous dit qu'on va
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique ou s'attaquer aux pertes de
biodiversité en poursuivant en fait un
objectif de croissance du pib s'est
totalement antinomique en fait ça veut
dire aggraver les causes du problème
cette obsession pour la pour la
croissance économique résulte d'un lourd
héritage on peut avoir de très nombreux
débats historiquement philosophiquement
même anthropologiquement extrêmement
intéressant sur le poids qui ont eu des
conceptions religieuses sûr
le chalet dit l'homme je vais y revenir
dominant la nature possesseur de la
nature sur la part du patriarcat dans
donc c'est là l'homme maître et
possesseur de la nature est aussi maître
et possesseur des femmes
je voudrais insister sur quelque chose
qui me paraît fondamental c'est que les
deux grands systèmes idéologiques qui
matrix en fait le débat politique en
france comme à l'échelle mondiale le
libéralisme le capitalisme et le
marxisme ont un point commun qui est
celui d'être productiviste et d'être
favorable à la croissance économique et
de conditionner l'arrêt la réalisation
de leurs projets politiques à
l'augmentation de la production
les uns parce qu'ils pensent que
l'accumulation toujours plus va par
théorie du ruissellement faire le
bonheur général les autres parce que la
cula le fait de faire grossir la taille
du gâteau va permettre de mieux
redistribuer les parts on doit
aujourd'hui envisager quelque chose de
nouveau c'est que la taille du gâteau
doit diminuer et qu'il faut en même
temps mieux partager les parts parce que
c'est le seul les seuls le seul le seul
chemin possible et on voit cette cette
grande convergence qui existe dans le
dans le débat politique on l'a vu aussi
de façon assez spectaculaire en terme
géopolitique à la pop 26 et c'est pas
une nouveauté puisque ça fait à peu près
trente ans que c'est la même chose à la
coop 26 vous avez toutes les grandes
puissances
quelles que soient leurs tensions
actuelles extrêmement forte quelles que
soient leurs points de désaccord
géopolitique qui sont toutes d'accord
pour ne rien faire ou presque on faire
semblant de faire par rapport à
l'accélération du réchauffement
climatique et on présente en 2021 comme
une victoire diplomatique obtenu de
haute lutte que le mot énergies fossiles
et le mot charbon c'est pour vous dire
où on en est soit inscrit dans un texte
international pour le climat pour la
première fois depuis 30 ans et en fait
ce set c'est là les règles du jeu des
coop depuis 1992 sont fondés sur un
traité international
qui dit dans son article 3 alinéa 5
qu'on a le droit de prendre aucune
mesure même unilatérale à l'échelle d'un
pays en faveur du climat qui pourrait
contrarier le développement du commerce
international et qui pourrait contrarier
la poursuite de l'objectif de croissance
économique c'est à dire que c'est
inscrit dans la règle de départ qu'on
n'a pas le droit de s'attaquer aux
causes du problème donc moi pour moi le
blocage c'est celui là et il appelle une
réponse qui est effectivement un projet
politique de décroissance alors
décroissance au sens de la réduction de
notre empreinte écologique à l'échelle
macroéconomique c'est à dire de la
réduction de notre consommation
d'énergie et de matières premières pour
faire grandir notre bien-être autrement
qu'en continuant de détruire la terre
et nos conditions de vie voilà je suis
hyper courte pour laisser de la place
comme je remarque a dépassé
je rattraperai
merci beaucoup à tous les deux pour vos
interventions je vais vous poser
quelques questions qui nous viennent du
chat et des personnes qui regardent en
ligne donc on nous a posé la question de
ce que représentait la promesse de la
france d'arrêter de financer les projets
incluant du charbon est ce que c'est une
grande annonce est ce que c'est au
contraire quelque chose qui est assez
dérisoire et j'avais aussi une question
sur le blocage politique alors
effectivement c'est s'intéresser aux
conséquences pas aux symptômes mais une
question ça serait est ce que les
citoyens sont suffisamment sensibilisés
au changement climatique et à ses
impacts pour pouvoir entendre parler de
décroissance étant donné les changements
que vous avez présenté monsieur
jancovici et notamment étant donné le
tir de barrage qui ont reçu plusieurs
mairies colo quand ils ont mis en oeuvre
des mesures qui par exemple l'arrêt de
la viande dans les cantines à lyon qui
n'était même pas pour des raisons
écologiques qui était pour des raisons
sanitaires donc voilà comment on
réconcilie cet impératif de d'appuyer
sur la [ __ ] de frein avec avec la
les citoyens et la politique ok je
connais je commence alors sur les
promesses sur le sur le charbon en fait
donc la france finance à l'international
de nouvelles capacités d'exploitation
des énergies fossiles en apportant la
garantie de l'état au travers d'un
dispositif qui s'appelle les aides à
l'exportation
donc du charbon il y en a pas
nécessairement eu dans les années
récentes mais par contre du pétrole et
du gaz oui ce sont au cours des derniers
dix dernières années 9 milliards d'euros
de garanties de l'état qui ont été
consacrés à des nouvelles capacités
d'exploitation d'énergies fossiles de
par le monde dans des pays où il faut
bien comprendre puisqu'il s'agit du
yémen de l'irak du mozambique
actuellement est sur la table une
décision attendue du gouvernement
français sur du gaz russe dans
l'arctique
il faut bien comprendre qu'en fait il
n'y avait pas la garantie publique s'il
n'y avait pas la garantie de l'état les
exploitent l'exploitation des énergies
fossiles lancer dans ces pays est
infinançable vous n'avez pas une banque
qui irait en fait dans des régions du
monde qui sont en général extrêmement
dangereuse qui reste il n'y avait pas
une garantie publique
donc c'est effectivement un pur scandale
est
certainement vous avez vu ce qui s'est
passé pendant la coop 26 ou vous avez un
certain nombre de pays volontaires qui
ont pris un texte d'appel pour dire on
doit complètement arrêté la création de
nouvelles capacités d'énergie fossile
c'est d'ailleurs ce que dit l'agencé
internationale à l'énergie depuis
notamment 2018 c'est à dire pas de
nouveau de nouvelles de nouveaux forages
pétroliers pas de nouvelle exploitation
gazière etc la france a été acculé une
fille née à signer ce texte est dans la
journée même vous avez eu une sorte de
rectificatif de bercy disant que ça ne
remettait pas en cause ce que la france
avait prévu pour l'instant notamment de
continuer à financer de nouvelles
exploitations gazière jusqu'en 2035
sur les citoyens sont-ils suffisamment
informés
des fois moi j'ai l'impression que les
citoyens sont beaucoup plus informés que
un certain nombre de deux hauts
fonctionnaires
ou de ce que je veux dire c'est que la
population me paraît parfaitement
consciente de
l'accélération du réchauffement
climatique deux tiers des jeunes sont en
situation d co anxiété et cet éco
anxiété touche aussi les adultes il est
impossible pour n'importe quel humain
normalement constitué
quand vous voyez des humains mis dans
des salles de refroidissement au canada
quand vous voyez les méga-feux autour de
la méditerranée les inondations en
belgique en allemagne le métro en chine
complètement inondé tout le monde est
imprégné en fait par parle angoisses
existentielles
auxquelles nous nous confronte
l'accélération en cours du réchauffement
climatique et le fait qu' on a le
sentiment d'entrer dans l'époque des
cataclysmes donc les citoyens sont
conscients être conscient est une chose
être informé en est effectivement une
haute et pour moi il n'y a pas de hasard
à ce que les citoyennes et les citoyens
membres de la convention citoyenne pour
le climat une fois qu'ils aient entendu
les climatologues et un certain nombre
de scientifiques ont ensuite produit des
propositions qui sont porteuses d'une
rupture totale avec le consumérisme qui
sont des propositions à portée de main
et on dit quand on leur posait votre
question quel est le principal blocage à
l'action pour le climat ont répondu
l'obsession pour la croissance
économique
parce et c'est pour ça que je vous
disais en premier point la première
bataille c'est la bataille du diagnostic
la première bataille c'est une grande
action d'éducation populaire en france
partout du top management des
entreprises jusqu'à tous les services
publics de la préfecture de département
jusqu aux administrations centrales
partout partout partout
sur le diagnostic exact de ce qui est en
train de se passer parce que c'est la
manière de libérer en fait toute la
créativité toutes les intelligences
toute l'inventivité sur les solutions et
tant qu'on ne fait pas ça tant qu'il ya
un hiatus en fait sur le constat
on perd on perd un temps infini donc oui
il faut informer les citoyens encore
plus sur les maires sur les mers
écologistes ça fait partie du jeu
derrière il ya une bataille politique il
ya ce que j'avais appelé moi front anti
l'écologie donc c'est toutes les
caricatures sur les amish et cetera et
cetera donc oui il ya une bataille
politique autour de tout de tout
changement sur l'écologie c'est c'est un
combat qu'il faut assumer et qu'il faut
affronter de face
qui pour ma part ne m'impressionne pas
une dernière question qui nous vient du
tchat et après on passera aux questions
du public donc encore une fois vous avez
juste à vous
non c'est pas ça je vais juste un tout
petit peu parce que ce qu'ils mangeaient
trop part et à l'heure sur la partie
sensibilisation information
je pense qu'il ya une différence
importante entre avoir souvent entendu
parler de quelque chose et avoir bien
compris de quoi il est question est donc
tout dépend de ce qu'on attend des gens
si on attend qu'il soit suffisamment
sensibilisés aujourd'hui pour derrière
un problème et j'aimerais bien que
quelqu'un s'en occupe je pense qu'on y
aller sans aucun n'y a pas de débat là
dessus si on attend des gens qu'ils
soient capables d'agir c'est à dire
d'avoir en tête les bon ordre de
grandeur les bonnes priorités les bonnes
contrepartiste r je peux faire ça mais
je peux pas faire ça en même temps et
c'est là pour le coup je pense qu'on n'y
est pas
et c'est la raison pour laquelle avant
de démarrer cette discussion on était
dans le bureau de votre directeur qui se
demandaient comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait donner dans cette école plus de
connaissances factuelles techniques qui
permettent derrière d'en faire quelque
chose dans un métier où qui permettent
d'en faire quelque chose dans une
fonction donc il ya une différence entre
dire je suis d'accord c'est un problème
et être capable de s'en emparer on parle
pas du même du même degré d'information
qui il faut avoir en main c'était juste
ça je voulais préciser si je peux
rebondir sur ce que dit jean marc avec
lequel je suis totalement d'accord en
fait aujourd'hui les débats sur
l'écologie sont sont plaints de
controverse dans lequel les gens sont
souvent peau mais alors ces voiliers
faut-il ou pas des voitures électriques
faut-il ou pas des éoliennes
faut-il ou pas
les débats sur l'alimentation et c est
en fait dans pour pour faire les bons
choix il ya besoin de boussole les bonne
boussole elles sont basées sur une
analyse clinique factuelle de la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes
d'accord
une dernière question qui provient du
chat et puis après on vous laissera
poser vos questions vous pourrez
alors pour poser des questions il suffit
d'aller dans le couloir et et de délai
au micro
sylvain je te laisse poser une question
et après je prendrai la question du
château
alors la question du chat
vaut-il mieux prévenir le réchauffement
climatique va essayer d'atténuer encore
les effets du changement climatique ou
au stade assez pessimiste que vous avez
dressé plutôt s'y préparer
voilà par crainte
je pense qu'on a la même à la même
réponse les deux en fait
c'est à dire que
on est dans une urgence absolue mais il
est encore
on est encore dans un horizon de temps
ou
on peut c'est ce qui découle d'ailleurs
du dernier du dernier rapport du giec et
si on agit maintenant de façon cohérente
radical rapide etc
on peut encore
limiter l'ampleur du réchauffement
climatique après on bascule
dans des phénomènes qui sont hors de
contrôle quand on dit limiter ça veut
pas dire se préserver de tous les
impacts et donc oui effectivement on
doit maintenant considéré en fait qu'il
s'agit qui va y avoir des conséquences
certaines pour une partie d'entre elles
vous savez qu'elles sont irréversibles
en particulier en ce qui concerne
l'élévation du niveau de la mer et la
fonte des glaces c'est à dire que ça on
y aura droit de toute façon quand bien
même on arriverait à la neutralité
carbone demain matin donc ça veut dire
des conséquences certaines du point de
vue des événements climatiques extrêmes
et des événements au long cours mais qui
auquel on peut
encore essayer de s'organiser pour faire
face mais auquel il faut se préparer et
donc ça veut dire pour moi que c'est
désormais une question de sécurité
nationale ce qui est très nouveau dans
le débat public
parce que voyez on considérer que bon
c'est écolo là avec leur les sujets qui
les préoccupent c'était pas du tout
l'écologie n'était pas du tout considéré
comme un enjeux de protection civile de
la population et de sécurité au sens
premier du terme désormais ça l'est donc
ça l'est évidemment par rapport aux
catastrophes et aux événements
climatiques extrêmes on peut parler ce
qui s'est passé dans la vallée de
l'arroux iard on peut parler d'irma on
peut parler des incendies qu'il ya eu
dans le var cet été où les pompiers vous
disent qu'il ya eu un comportement de l'
incendie totalement anormal et qu'ils
n'avaient jamais vu ça de leur vie enfin
peut on peut continuer à développer mais
ça vaut aussi pour des évolutions
où l'on court et qui impacte en premier
lieu les questions d'alimentation et de
souveraineté alimentaire
donc il faut organiser notre résilience
et donc ma réponse c'est les deux
merci beaucoup on peut passer aux
questions dans la salle où
une question concernant finalement les
différents programmes qui ont été
portées par la primaire des écologistes
je sais que vous êtes particulièrement
intéressés par un sujet je voulais
savoir comment on parle d'une urgence
absolue d'extrême urgence absolue on a
tous cette cette notion en tête et
pourtant on voit aussi un parti qui qui
se fait entendre sur d'autres questions
est-ce qu'il va pas un risque de
dilution ajustements porter ce message
d'urgence absolue pour la décennie la
décennie crucial que nous vivons sur
d'autres sujets de société comment
vraiment réussir un dvd à faire adhérer
les france à ces questions je n'ai pas
trop compris dans
ce cas pas un sujet de dispersion au
sein des valeurs
on va en prendre plusieurs à la suite
bonsoir et merci beaucoup pour votre
intervention j'avais deux petites
questions l'une sur le nucléaire trouve
que la question a été un peu éludé et on
a besoin d'en parler quand même parce
que les investissements qu'on décide de
faire aujourd'hui vont nous engager pour
prendre 40 ans donc je crois que c'est
très important et on pourrait investir
je crois dans les renouvelables est ma
seconde question concerne les sud et les
pays qui ne bénéficient pas d'un niveau
de développement comment les intégrer
dans cette transition et comment on fait
pour
pour leur permettre d'accéder à un
niveau de vie qui leur permet un peu de
bien-être justement tout en interne
attendait sobriété merci bon et on va
prendre une dernière question à gauche
enfin à droite
bonsoir merci pour vos interventions
deux questions du coup très courte
première question comment est-ce qu'on
traite les émissions importés je prends
mon téléphone chaussures qu'il ya des
objets qui viennent de 10 pays
différents mais abbey même si j'achète
cms j'aurais quand même au moins les
matières premières qui viendront pas de
france
donc est-ce qu'il faut démondialiser est
ce qu'il faut ça ne pas dire les achète
cher mais au fait
est ce qu'il faut démondialiser est-ce
qu'il faut réduire la consommation c'est
suffisant dans un monde qui est déjà
complètement mondialisé et deuxième
question
en tout cas à mon époque quand j'étais à
sciences po en parler quand même très
peu de décroissance
on avait plutôt on parlait plutôt de
découplage et c est ce qu aujourd'hui
dans les universités c'est en train de
changer
je crois que vous travaillez avec
quelques universités peut-être plutôt
des écoles d'ingénieurs sur cet aspect
là mais je pense que ce serait crise est
parce qu ici on a quand même plusieurs
futurs être dans cet album et décideurs
voilà ce que les choses changent à ce
niveau là
alors qui veut commencer à répondre à la
première question était sur les verts
je laisse la politesse
la première concernait
moi je
n'ai pas compris en fait les
sous-entendus de la question qui n'était
pas qu'ils n'étaient pas assez explicite
puisque bon moi je n'ai pas le sentiment
que les écologistes ne portent pas
l'enjeu de l'urgence écologique donc je
sais pas à quoi vous faisait référence
exactement en parlant de dispersion
plein d'autres
mais quelle autre concrètement
alors voilà c'est ce à quoi je
m'attendais donc c'est ce à quoi je ne
suis pas d'accord en fait il peut pas y
avoir deux en fait si vous voulez le la
transforma le changement qu'on doit
accomplir
c'est d'abord comment dire c'est d'abord
de la physique
mais c'est aussi de la culture certes
nous sommes héritiers de croissance par
exemple ma génération j'espère pas la
vôtre a été biberonné à l'idée qu'il y
avait eu un truc super dans l'histoire
qui étaient les trente glorieuses et
qu'il fallait absolument courir à
vouloir revenir à l'époque des trente
glorieuses
donc il ya un changement culturel à
opérer c'est ce que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure sur le point commun entre eux
les idéologies venant du libéralisme et
celles venant du marxisme et il ya
excusez-moi l'impossibilité d'accomplir
cette transformation en restant dans le
système du patriarcat c'est à dire que
tout ce qui doit changer dans notre
rapport au vivant dans notre rapport à
la nature c'est aussi des choses à
changer dans notre rapport des humains
entre eux et c'est la nécessité d'abolir
toute forme de domination et tous les
mécanismes de domination et c'est ce que
porte l'écoféminisme et c'est pour ça
que l'écoféminisme et la décroissance
s'est vraiment
c'est les doigts d'une même main en fait
ça marche complètement ensemble et
l'écoféminisme a toujours d'ailleurs
dans celle qui en a inventé la notion
françoise d'eaubonne combat taisent
parce que limite isme ce que la
philosophe simone weil appelé limite
isme c'est à dire 7 cette idée de
déracinement par rapport à nos
conditions d'existence biologique et par
rapport à notre rapport à la terre donc
c'est pas pour moi c'est pas une comment
dire une dispersion
de parler d'éco féminisme est par
ailleurs à l'échelle internationale il
n'y a pas de hasard aujourd'hui à ce que
les deux les deux seuls grands
mouvements sociaux d'ampleur
internationale sont d'une part le
mouvement de la jeunesse mobilisée pour
le climat et d'autres parmi tout est en
fait il ya un lien entre les deux est en
fait il ya une cohérence entre les deux
est en fait c'est ça qui va changer le
monde donc pour moi la décroissance et
l'écoféminisme ça marche ensemble
je veux bien commencé sur le nucléaire
parce que visiblement ça le débat nous
attend dès ce soir et jean marc duret
ensuite linverse de moi
je vais je vais peut-être j'ai peut-être
justement commenter cette cette remarque
en vous racontant quelque chose j'ai été
j'étais ministre de l'écologie et de
l'énergie donc en charge de la conduite
du débat national sur la transition
énergétique en 2012 et tous les experts
que nous avions consulté avait fait des
scénarios et tous les scénarios disait
avaient un point commun voyez dans tous
les futurs énergétique possible pour la
france c'est qu'il n'y avait aucun
chemin pour atteindre nos objectifs de
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre qui ne commençait pas par
diviser par deux la consommation
d'énergie en france
c'est à dire que quel que soit le mix
énergétique
futur le premier effort l'urgence
absolue c'est de réduire la consommation
d'énergie autrement dit d' organiser la
décroissance énergétique
et en fait on est dans une situation en
france où le débat sur le nucléaire il
sert de paratonnerre
pour dévier l'énergie de nos
intelligences de cet effort là qu est le
premier à faire et et servir de
dérivatif et étouffer le débat sur la
décroissance énergétique
d'autre part présenter la construction
d'un nouveau programme nucléaire comme
une solution pour le climat alors
qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas capable de
construire un au pm que les op r dont il
est question coûte cher que les hôtes et
air dont il est question ne verrait pas
le jour avant 2045 alors que tout à
l'heure je vous ai dit que les solutions
ce qui compte c'est ce qu'on fait entre
maintenant et 2030 pour moi n'est pas
quelque chose de sérieux enfin ayant été
en responsabilité de la sûreté nucléaire
le débat sur le nucléaire pour moi ne se
situe pas seulement dans un débat
de moyens de production énergétique et
d'impact sur le réchauffement climatique
mais aussi comme un sujet de sécurité et
de risque
et quand je lis le témoignage du lanceur
d'alert de tricastin
pour celles et ceux qui l'ont qui l'ont
lu il y a des motifs d'inquiétudes
sérieuses sur la sûreté nucléaire qui
fait que moi je ne suis pas favorable à
ce que la france lance la construction
d'un nouveau programme nucléaire on peut
avoir des débats sur l'avenir du parc
nucléaire existant moi j'ai ma vision
est celle d'un ordre des priorités
extrêmement clair d'abord réduire la
consommation d'énergie ensuite priorité
absolue à la sortie des énergies
fossiles et c'est seulement dans un
troisième terme que l'on peut envisager
de diminuer le parc nucléaire existant à
mesure que ces progrès sont réalisés et
en tenons compte des transferts
des énergies fossiles vers l'électricité
on continue ce sujet par sujet c'est
mieux
peut-être que ça vous brûle de parler du
nucléaire
alors je suis d'accord avec presque tout
avec quelques nuances importantes
la première jouée par les chiffres
aujourd'hui quand vous regardez la
quantité d'énergie qui est utilisé par
les machines françaises
vous avez en ordre de grandeur 2000
milliards de kilowattheures qui sont
utilisés par an par les machines
françaises 1 2 mille milliards c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'énergie finale c
incluent les énergies renouvelables y
compris le bois est là dedans vous avez
à peu près 400 dans 400 sur 2000 qui
viennent du nucléaire 400 milliards de
kilowattheures donc si on divise par
deux premier objectif auquel je souscris
tout à fait il nous en reste 1000 à
fournir
dont il ya 400 de nucléaire donc si on
dit le rsa doit être des énergies
renouvelables faut fournir 600 de
renouvelables 600 milliards de
kilowattheures et l'a1 faut commencer à
faire des calculs pour voir si c'est
sympa simple et si dans ces six ans
malgré la difficulté le prix le et
cetera bah en fait on a pas meilleur
compte quand même de temps en temps
d'essayer d'en rajouter un peu parce que
ce sera encore plus dur de rajouter
beaucoup de renouvelables c'est dans
cette dans cette case là qu'il faut
débattre et même si on divise par trois
ce qui au premier ordre représente une
vraie décroissance du pouvoir d'achat
dont je vous rappelle qu'aujourd'hui
tout le monde dit que c'est le prochain
sujet de la présidentielle eh bien ça
ferait encore six ou sept cents
milliards de kilowattheures à fournir
dont 402 nucléaire aujourd'hui
donc le débat doit être pragmatique il
doit porter sur des chiffres
la deuxième chose que je voudrais
mentionner c'est que c'est très
différent de faire un objet de faire un
système c'est clair qu'aujourd'hui s'est
considérablement plus simple de faire
une éolienne additionnel que de faire un
réacteur additionnel 0 débat là dessus
par contre à la question qui est ce que
c'est plus simple de faire un système
basé sur beaucoup de renouvelables que
de faire un système basé sur beaucoup de
nucléaire est bien là la réponse elle
est beaucoup moins évidentes parce que
les renouvelables qu'on s'est développée
aujourd'hui sont des renouvelables non
pilotable c'est pas le cas de toutes les
renouvelables l'hydroélectricité pas
réforme est parfaitement pilotable le
bois est raisonnablement pilotable mais
celle qu'on développe aujourd'hui ne le
sont pas le soleil et le vent est de
faire un système basé là dessus c'est
compliqué si on veut par ailleurs
conservé une organisation dans laquelle
les cours démarrent à sciences po à 9
heures ou à 8 heures je pense que vous
êtes fait la grasse mat ou pas ici
qui est du vent ou pas de vent du soleil
ou pas de soleil et un monde dans lequel
le métro il avance à sept heures qui est
du vent ou pas de vent et du soleil ou
pas de soleil et que votre dentiste il
va vous extraire la molaire à 8 heures
qui est du vent ou pas devant ces
agréables conseille pas d'y aller trop
souvent et où le restaurant va vous
servir à 12h30 qui est du vent pas
devant et c'est donc aujourd'hui on a
basé une société sur les horaires on a
une société prévisible organisé basé sur
les horaires ça n'a pas toujours été le
cas un nos ancêtres chasseurs de
mammouths il n'était pas du tout basé
sur les horaires le mammouth leur disais
pas je te préviens tuque le zigouiller à
3h45 de l'après midi parce qu'à ce
moment là je vais passer comme ça que ça
se passait et pour moudre la farine il y
avait du vent
vous êtes la farine et pas devant ce
n'est pas de farine donc nos ancêtres
ont vécu dans un monde dans lequel les
choses étaient peu prévisibles ça a
donné un monde très différent alors on
peut très bien le retrouver l'espace y
survivra très bien je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure l'essentiel de notre vie on a eu
un monde 100 % renouvelable par contre
il faut bien comprendre la contrepartie
la contrepartie encore une fois c'est
que le monde pilotable 1 est un monde
dans lequel c'est compliqué de se passer
à la fois des fossiles et du nucléaire
sauf dans quelques pays béni des dieux
où ils peuvent tout faire avec des
barrages donc il faut envahir l'europe
du nord
envoyez
biens de la population
mais
sinon voilà c'est ça le sessad débat
qu'il faut avoir alors je ne rentrerai
pas ce soir parce qu'on n'a pas le temps
dans tous les inconvénients réels ou
supposés du nucléaire parce que là on y
passerait la nuit je vais juste dire une
chose les médias français ont eu
tendance 1 globalement à parler des
inconvénients du nucléaire au delà de la
place des inconvénients du nucléaire
dans l'ensemble des inconvénients
auxquels nous devons faire face sur
cette planète ils ont quand même je le
dis parfois d'une manière un peu
caricaturale en disant il ya un ouvrier
qui se laisse tomber un marteau sur le
pied dans une centrale nucléaire cela
fait un quart de page dans le monde où
les chocs sont bouchés dans une centrale
nucléaire incarne donc
du coup je vais envoyer sur l'empreinte
carbone et puis après je te passe la
balle son empreinte carbone alors
l'empreinte carbone mais je suis très en
phase avec delphine sur la partie de
toute façon l'urgence c'est la baisse
alors mon corps mon programme idéal vu
de ma fenêtre sur le nucléaire il est
pas de déployer des opm partout il est
d'accélérer de mettre un énorme coup
d'accélérateur sur la quatrième
génération est il pas dans un truc que
j'aurais dû dire aussi encore avancé
qu'il faut bien comprendre que de sortir
des griffes des limites planétaires dont
on vous a parlé ce soir c'est pas une
économie tranquille pour moi c'est ce
que j'appelle une économie guerre on est
dans un monde dans lequel il faut
avancer à peu près à la vitesse à
laquelle on avance quand on a un pays en
économie de guerre
c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre alors ça
veut dire que les rythmes d'avancer d'un
certain nombre de choses changent
complètement pour certains ça ne change
rien parce que
même si vous êtes en économie guéant
fait toujours un bébé en neuf mois ne se
change pas donc il ya des trucs on ne
change pas voilà et puis il ya des trucs
pour lesquelles ça peut changer très
très significativement la vitesse à
laquelle on avance sur le nucléaire moi
mon programme idéal c'est de foncer sur
la quatrième génération c'est-à-dire de
mettre un paquet de milliards sur le
développement de telle sorte qu'on
puisse avoir à l'horizon d'une vingtaine
d'années un la capacité à déployer des
réacteurs de quatrième génération on
boucle avec des ep r le temps le temps
de faire la jonction mais on n'en débat
pas plus que ça voilà c'est ça mon c'est
ça la manière donc je verrai les choses
sur le programme nucléaire c'est pas du
tout comme ça que le gouvernement et je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec delphine
quand elle dit le nucléaire est un cache
sexe des gens qui veulent pas entendre
parler de baisse de la consommation
d'énergie 100 % d'accord et c'est la
raison pour laquelle les plus pro
nucléaires sont aussi les plus climato
sceptiques les plus vieux les plus
convaincus que le progrès va nous sauver
en fait tout ça étant même paquet ce qui
de mon point de vue il n'a pas de
cohérence propre mais c'est quand même
comme ça que ça s'articule aujourd'hui
dans l'opinion est souvent le plus à
droite
c'est aussi une réalité sociologique
alors sur la partie empreinte carbone il
ya effectivement une énorme partie des
émissions qui sont la contrepartie des
objets que nous avons à notre
disposition qui ont eu lieu hors de
france
donc quand vous achetez aujourd'hui
l'électronique il n'y a pas une usine de
smartphones en france il n'y a pas une
usine qui fait des dalles d'écrans n'y a
pas une usine de microprocesseurs sauf
une quelques usines de
stmicroelectronics à grenoble donc vous
avez en gros à peu près rien qui vient
de france quand vous achetez du textile
pour l'essentiel ça a été fabriqué hors
de france donc vous achetez de la plate
forme pétrolière 6 et synthétiques ou
des champs de coton qui sont pas en
france non plus si c'est du coton
quand vous achetez aujourd'hui une
petite voiture l'essentiel du temps elle
est parfaite en france et c'est donc il
ya énormément d'objets qui sont pas
faits en france de telle sorte que si on
veut raisonné sur le lien entre les
émissions et notre style de vie
c'est sur ce qu'on appelle l'empreinte
carbone qu'il faut raisonner et pas sur
les émissions domestiques donc il faut
raisonner sur la totalité des émissions
qui sont la contrepartie de notre mode
de vie et ses émissions là ont
significativement augmenté entre 1990 et
l'apogée on va dire qu'il se balade aux
alentours de 2000 alors que les
émissions domestiques on pc etc sur les
émissions domestiques ont des tenues au
titre des accords internationaux et
c'est sur les émissions domestiques
qu'on a une stratégie nationale bas
carbone d'accord mais c'est par contre
c'est sur les émissions de l'empreinte
carbone que nous avons un une vraie
contrepartie à notre autre un autre mode
de vie donc il faudrait effectivement
le suivre et agir dessus parce qu'en
fait si on parle de notre responsabilité
de consommateurs on va dire c'est bien
de l'empreinte carbone dont on parle
c'est pas de nos émissions domestiques
il ya un troisième poste des missions
auxquelles on pourrait s'intéresser
c'est les émissions induites par les
exportations françaises parce que dans
les exportations françaises et notamment
des avions
et les avions ça émet un tout petit peu
quand on s'en sert aujourd'hui ça et
même même 99 fois plus que quand on les
fabrique un avion c'est un gros
réservoir de kérosène volant donc on
pourrait aussi intégrer dans l'empreinte
carbone de la france les émissions
d'utilisation des produits vendus par
les français voilà ça serait encore un
autre calcul qu'on peut le faire
je continue
alors je sors juste un rebond sur le sur
le nucléaire
pour dire qu'en fait on est dans un
débat voyez pendant la révolution
française il y avait tout ce qu'ils
voulaient abolir la monarchie puis il y
avait les autres ceux qui voulaient
abolir la monarchie il avait plein de
débat entre eux et donc aujourd'hui je
prends cette comparaison parce que il
faut qu'il y ait des débats c'est bien
qu'ils aient des débats mais je pense
que nous sommes conscients jean-marc
comme moi même que nous sommes dans le
camp des résistants qui sont pour
abandonner l'obsession pour l'apa sens
économique quand bien même nous pouvons
avoir des débats francs et intelligente
notamment sur le sur le nucléaire je
voulais prendre la question sur les je
vais revenir sur les émissions à porter
très brièvement mais sur les pays du sud
en fait parce que dans
le les défis climatiques la question de
la justice est fondamentale et en fait
cette question de justice elle s'oppose
à l'intérieur de nos pays comme à
l'échelle internationale dans les mêmes
termes quasiment c'est à dire que si on
re si on compte en empreinte carbone
l'empreinte carbone historique des pays
dits développés
qui ont développé massivement les
machines les énergies fossiles
qui ont
construit leur développement aussi sur
l'accaparement des richesses d'autres
d'autres nations cf la question de
l'impérialisme du colonialisme etc vous
avez d'ailleurs vous savez dans tous les
débats sur caen a commencé
l'anthropocène dont les géologues
répondent que ça a commencé avec les
essais nucléaires parce que dans des
milliers d'années on retrouvera leurs
traces dans les couches géologiques mais
vous avez des débats qui disent ça a
commencé avec la colonisation d'autres
ça a commencé avec le capitalisme à ce
moment là il parle de capital au sein
bref donc cette question de justice elle
est fondamentale et de la même façon
qu'aujourd'hui en france vous avez des
personnes qui ont des modes de vie à 30
tonnes 40 tonnes de co2 et d'autres
personnes qui peuvent être les plus
modestes qui vont être à 4 tonnes 6
tonnes de co2 par an à l'échelle
internationale vous avez la même chose
et on ne peut résoudre le on ne peut
réussir les transformations à opérer que
par plus de justice et en fait d'où la
tension qui a notamment à chaque coop
sur les pays qui viennent dire d'abord
la question des pertes et dommages c'est
à dire les pays qui vont être rayés de
la carte
qui viennent dire comment notre
situation est prise en compte puisque on
va être purement et simplement
éliminées de la surface de la terre
c'est notamment la question de tous les
pays qui militent vous savez pour
l'objectif de 1,5 degré même si tout le
monde sait qu'il ne sera pas tenu parce
que en fait entre 1 5 et 2 degrés il ya
des différences pour un certain nombre
de pays qui sont absolument notable leur
vie ou leur mort en dépendent de cette
différence entre 1,5 ou 2 degrés et
c'est la même chose à l'intérieur de nos
pays du coup ça amène à une
clarification sur la définition de la
décroissance
l'économiste timothée paris qui la
définit comme la réduction de notre
empreinte écologique dans les pays dits
riches ou développer justement pour
intégrer cette dimension des rapports
nord-sud on peut néanmoins leur
souhaiter de construire un autre modèle
de développement que de copier celui qui
est en train de détruire nos conditions
d'existence sur la sur les émissions
importés il faut que l'empreinte carbone
deviennent la règle de calcul
et cette notion d'empreinte carbone elle
est absolument fondamentale notamment
par rapport à des arguments que vous
pouvez entendre de temps en temps dans
le débat public et le hac wabo nisme à
quoi bon est ce que la france
ferait pour elles mêmes des choix
exemplaire puisque nous représentons je
connais plus le chief parker jean-marc
que 1 % et 1 % des émissions mondiales
de co2 alors à quoi ça sert et en fait
le 1 % c'est effectivement les émissions
sur notre sol ça tient pas compte du
fait que notre bétail manche du soja qui
a contribué à détruire la forêt
amazonienne
et ainsi de suite et donc effectivement
notre en notre empreinte notre
consommation intérieure
a des conséquences partout dans le monde
et donc nos choix ont des conséquences
partout dans le monde d'autre part c'est
là qu'on voit le lien qui lie à entre
les transformations à accomplir et la
relève au casier relocalisation de
l'économie est en fait si vous ne
comptez pas en empreinte carbone
mais que vous montez seulement en
emprunter écolo on emprunte émissions de
gaz à effet de serre sur notre sol ça
peut être complètement antinomique avec
le fait de vouloir rapatrier telle ou
telle activité industrielle donc c'est
absolument fondamental de compter en
empreinte carbone et de se battre pour
la reconnaissance de l'empreinte carbone
à toutes les échelles nationales
européennes et internationales et je
salue le travail conseille pour le
climat
qui a beaucoup fait avancer
la réflexion et ont pris celle du
législateur en france donc on a réussi à
glisser quelques trucs dans le code de
l'énergie mais c'est pas encore ça
alors il nous reste 15 minutes donc je
crois qu'on a une question et on va
essayer après de commencer par là il y
avait une question sur le programme des
universités
et une question sur la mondialisation à
la question sur la modélisation en 15
secondes la mondialisation c'est du
pétrole donc moins de pétrole ce sera
moins de mondialisation voilà
non mais c'est exactement ça je dis rien
et le programme des universités et dent
pour le moment ça reste très
embryonnaire cette affaire là si vous
regardez la façon dont le ses sujets de
limites planétaires et ses sujets de
cadre des réflexions physiques sont pris
en compte aujourd'hui dans les
programmes d'enseignement
globalement on en est encore aux
balbutiements
globalement
donc il ya une question
vous m'entendez oui très bien à titre
personnel je m'interroge un peu sur ce
qu'impliquerait la décroissance en
termes de rapports de force
internationaux parce que si nous la
france décidons de nous appauvrir pour
réduire nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre donc pour la bonne cause ne
risque-t-on pas un jour de nous
retrouver en position de faiblesse
vis-à-vis de certaines puissances
étrangères rival notamment au plan
militaire nous pose cette question car
aujourd'hui la puissance d'un état y
compris militaires mais pas que dépend
beaucoup de sa prospérité économique
alors on peut concerner bonsoir merci à
vous pour pour la conférence alors
majoré une question par rapport à
l'union européenne est-ce que c'est
plutôt un bleu une source de blocage une
source de solutions sachant d'un côté on
a une législation qui met en avant le
marché commun
libre échange et la croissance
économique mais que de l'autre si jamais
on a un pouvoir politique vraiment très
écologique entre il ya un levier sur 440
millions d'habitants et les pays les
plus riches du monde
merci bonsoir madame bateau dans votre
intervention vous avez mentionné un
arthritiques qui serait en fait un
blocage aux négociations sur le climat
j'aimerais savoir jeu ça m'a fait penser
justement au traité sur la charte de
l'énergie qui est un traité à ses
secrets qui bloquent totalement les
actions climatiques alors comment vous
expliquer l'absence totale de la
question de la sortie de ce traité dans
le débat politique y compris chez les
verts et les différents partis de gauche
est-ce que c'est par manque de
connaissance ou par manque de courage
politique ou quelque chose d'autre
sachant que c'est quand même un traité
qui permet aux grandes industries
fossiles d'intenter des procès aux états
qui pour des milliards et des milliards
d'euros la france en a fait les frais
l'espagne en après ma question
on va s'arrêter là pour ce round ce je
ne sais pas qui veut dénoncer bon
ok bon on prend encore 2 minutes de
questions vous dépêchez vous de bien
déposé tu te seras le temps des réponses
je sais de wervicq donc bon soir donc
moi personnellement je suis étudiante en
première année à sciences po en double
licence avec en géosciences donc on a
lille et les sciences et les sciences et
sciences humaines ma question du coup
c'est sûr sur l'éducation il ya deux
semaines j'ai eu en tant que militant
j'ai eu l'occasion d'intervenir lors
d'un forum sur l'agriculture avec des
représentants en agro industrie des
représentants politiques et j'ai posé
une question simple qui a eu le rapport
du giec et agila enfin une surprise à
peine quelques mains se sont levés ma
première question c'est comment éduquer
nos dirigeants dont ses dirigeants
politiques et que les dirigeants
économiques la deuxième question du coup
c'est comment comment on va on va
éduquer les jeunes donc personnellement
je fais partie du mouvement une histoire
comme et de france qui est le mouvement
des dégrés mondiale peau qui m'a de
contrat va y beaucoup sur ces questions
notre proposition c'est d'apporter une
heure
deux cours un créneau d'une heure de
cours chaque semaine pendant tout le
secondaire sur les enjeux
interdisciplinaire donc qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ça et puis du coup à ma
troisième derrière dernière question du
coût apparemment notre nouveau directeur
vous a posé des questions là-dessus sur
comment on préfère à sciences po pour
mieux prendre en question prendre
[Musique]
désolé de faire en sorte que ces
questions soient soient étudiées du coup
ben quel était votre réponse quand il
faudrait poser cette question merci
merci et une minute pour une question à
gauche je vais faire encore plus court
c'était juste pour vous demander quel
niveau d'action serait peut-être le plus
pertinent comment travailler au niveau
international surtout sur ces
problématiques
merci bon ben c'est bon on va peut-être
passer aux réponses là il ya énormément
de questions
merci pour vos questions
décroissance et puissance militaire mais
plutôt pour toi ça non je joue bien
répondre aussi messieurs
je pense pas on
te dire un peu la chose alors d'abord
donc sur le sur la france et
l'international et la décroissance la
première chose que je voudrais dire
et qui vaut pour toutes formes d'actions
pour le climat ou pour le vivant qui
soit sérieuse c'est d'inviter à bannir
l'idée qu' il ne faut pas faire les
choses parce qu'on seraient les seuls à
le faire
parce qu'en fait si on est dans ce mode
de raisonnement là on ne fait rien
et en fait si on attend qu'il y ait un
consensus mondial et internationale pour
se décider à agir dans la bonne
direction
ben en fait personne ne fait rien et du
coup vous avez les coqs qui sont une
forme de je te tiens tu me tiens par la
barbichette pour ne rien faire et ça
c'est pas possible
et donc la france dans son histoire sur
de nombreuses questions a parfois été et
en général c'est ce qui fait plutôt
notre fierté la première au monde à
décider par exemple
d'abolir la monarchie dans un moment où
c'était le seul régime politique au
monde dans les pays dits développés de
l'époque et on peut multiplier des
exemples et dans les fois on a été en
retard dans notre histoire en général on
en est pas on n'a pas été les premiers
par exemple pour le droit de vote des
femmes et on peut multiplier donc il ya
vraiment ils ont peut pas être dans le
logiciel dont kikicé qui serait que
c'est les pays les plus émetteurs les
plus conservateurs et les plus
dépendants des énergies fossiles qui
tire les ficelles pour que rien ne bouge
sur lesquels on doit s'aligner parce
qu'à ce moment là on ne fait rien
deuxièmement est-ce qu'on est
aujourd'hui dans une situation de
puissance danon en fait on est dans une
situation de faiblesse et de dépendance
géostratégique majeur parce qu'on dépend
du gaz notamment de poutine mais pas que
parce qu'on dépend des importations
d'énergie fossile parce qu'on dépend des
supras produit des supraconducteurs fait
des semi conducteurs fait à l'autre bout
du monde et c'est donc en fait le fait
de concevoir une politique de
décroissance j'insiste en termes
macroéconomiques c'est à dire que ce qui
compte c'est la réduction globale de
notre empreinte écologique danger qui
est une qui est une stratégie aussi de
relocalisation de notre économie c'est
une stratégie de reprise de maîtrise de
contrôle et donc de souveraineté sur ce
qui est assez fondamental pour le tout
ce qui concerne notamment la sécurité du
pays est en tout cas justement de sortir
de cette situation de dépendance
géostratégique qui est un affaiblissent
un affaiblissement très important pour
la france mais aussi pour l'union
européenne sur l'union européenne moi je
alors c'est là que j'ai nuancer ce que
j'ai à dire c'est à dire qu'on est on
est par définition sur des enjeux qui
concerne l'humanité tout entière il n'y
a pas il n'y a pas de sujets qu'ils
soient à dimension plus
internationaliste que ceux de la lutte
efficace contre le réchauffement
climatique pour la biodiversité pour la
préservation de nos conditions de vie
sur terre à partir de là évidemment
qu'on a besoin de l'union européenne
évidemment qu'on a besoin même même les
coop leurs résultats sont totalement
insuffisants mais c'est un cadre
multilatéral et heureusement qu'il
existe on a besoin de multilatéralisme
on a besoin de l'union européenne et du
coup le problème qui est posé c'est
quelle est la politique de l'union
européenne de ce point de vue là en fait
aujourd'hui la politique notamment
énergétiques de l'union européenne ça a
été d'appliquer au secteur de l'énergie
les totems de l'ouverture des marchés
des marchés la concurrence libre et non
faussée et c'est au secteur de l'énergie
qui est un secteur qui par définition a
besoin d'une intensité capitalistique et
de choix de puissance publique qui sont
qui peuvent pas être dépendant de la
main invisible du marché et donc la
question prioritaire pour l'union
européenne c'est notamment celles que
j'ai évoqués sur sa dépendance aux
importations de pétrole de gaz et
d'énergie fossile et du coup je vous
invite puisque vous recevez je crois
amélie de mon chemin de montchalin
demain allez poser la question notamment
sur la charte de l'énergie comme ancien
ministre de chargé des affaires
européennes et savoir ce que la france
va faire dans la présidence française de
l'union européenne parce que c'est
effectivement une question très
importante sur l'éducation n'en on en a
déjà parlé
ce qu'on a dit avec jean-marc ont été on
était convergent puisque on avait déjà
travaillé ensemble sur cette question
c'est que l'enjeu dans l'éducation c'est
pas d'ajouter des cours en plus certes
c'est pas
d'ajouter des cours de matières
supplémentaires ou de matières nouvelle
même si on peut bien sûr selon les
formations en discuter c'est le contenu
de l'ensemble des enseignements dans
tous les domaines en quoi il tient
compte des limites planétaires du
réchauffement climatique et transmet les
connaissances factuelles de base
fondamentale quel que soit le métier
qu'on se décide donc on se destine à
faire et donc c'est ce qu'ont ceux qu'on
échangeait tout à l'heure avec votre
avec votre directeur en lui signalant
par ailleurs des ressources internes ou
publié aux presses de sciences po qui
sont très pertinentes telles que l'atlas
de l'anthropocène
moi
un pour essayer de de compléter un peu
donc sur la partie
diminution de l'empreinte et
sécurité intérieure parce que finalement
c'est de ça dont on parle
avec la puissance militaire
d'abord ce n'est pas aussi clair que ça
que une diminution de l'empreinte aille
avec une diminution des forces armées
parce qu'on peut très bien faire porter
l'effort partout ailleurs sauf là une
question de choix la deuxième chose
c'est que certes on pourrait considérer
que toutes choses égales par ailleurs
ainsi on a un tiers d'avion en moins on
est moins bien défendus sauf que cet
élément là il peut être très bien être
contrebalancé par tout un tas d'autres
domaines où on a un tiers de souci en
moins
si jamais on fait ce qui vaut au niveau
domestique donc s'il n'y a pas un lien
aussi direct que ça indépendamment du
fait que je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec l'idée que il ya un avantage au
premier qui se bougent les fesses dans
cette histoire est donc l'attentisme
nous dessert et il nous dessert d'autant
plus que toute façon on est dans la
seringue en ce qui concerne la quantité
de combustible fossile qu'on peut
rentrer en france puisque je voulais dit
tout à l'heure très rapidement mais on
est déjà contraint sur le pétrole et on
les en fait depuis 2006 à cause du pic
de production du conventionnel suivi
maintenant du pic tout-pétrole
vraisemblable on est dans la seringue
depuis 2005 sur le gaz ce que le gaz est
une énergie régional et la mer du nord a
passé son pic en 2005 et on est dans la
seringue sur le charbon depuis les
années 50 bien avant qu'on s'occupe du
climat ce que le charbon est une énergie
domestique et que le continent européen
ayant tapé dans ses mines de charbon
depuis deux siècles puis de production
et en 1914 en grande bretagne on dire eh
bien le charbon de toute façon dont on
consomme de moins en moins climat ou pas
climat donc en ce qui concerne l'europe
de toute façon la contraction
énergétique est à l'oeuvre c'est ce que
je disais tout à l'heure et donc la
question de savoir comment est-ce que je
défaut s'ils lisent de façon gérer
plutôt que de façon suivie c'est une
question même pas pour dans un an c'est
une question pour aujourd'hui il a tout
de suite c'est une question qui est déjà
sur la table depuis dix ans sauf qu on
la comprend pas comme ça donc on tape à
côté mais c'est une question pour tout
de suite et maintenant voilà donc là
qu'il ya même plus d'état d'âme à avoir
pour moi le débat est terminé là dessus
à cause d'eux à cause de ce que je viens
d'expliquer est ce que l'union
européenne est un obstacle ou inouïe ned
bat les deux mon général aujourd'hui
c'est bien le problème c'est à dire que
c'est à la fois
une source de réglementation que les
états n'oserait pas passer eux mêmes moi
j'ai le souvenir d'un truc dont tu te
souviens de tête c'est reach aucun
gouvernement national n'aurait passé
reach aucun reach c'était un règlement
qui étaient extrêmement exigeants sur
les substances mises en circulation par
les producteurs ou importateurs de
produits chimiques moi je me rappelle
très bien à l'époque je connaissais très
bien le direct le directeur général de
l'union des industries chimiques il est
elle à réguler tous les jours du matin
au soir comme un putois en expliquant
qu'on allait tuer la chimie européenne
bon c'est pas du tout ça qui s'est passé
en fait trois ans après il était ravi en
dix ans on nous oblige à faire des trucs
que les autres savent pas faire donc en
fait c'est une protection contre les
importations pourquoi donc là la
réglementation européenne peut être à la
fois d'une grande aide et par ailleurs
l'europe est un énorme obstacle à cause
de son niveau d'alerté de son idolâtrie
du marché
et du fait que je crois que c'est une
des seules constitution au monde qui
inclut le mot croissance c'est qu'il est
écrit article 3 du traité de lisbonne
que l'europe dise la croissance je crois
pas que ce soit mis dans la constitution
française enfin je les polluants détails
mais je crois pas que ce soit dans la
constitution d' aucun état au monde
qu'on vise la croissance donc
le
l'europe je le redis à la fois un
problème mais une solution
voilà
traité sur la charte de l'énergie je
suis d'accord c'est un truc un peu
technique donc si on en parle il faut
passer dix minutes comment est-ce qu'on
éduque les
dirigeants et les jeunes bas en
cherchant à le faire
alors de le faire
le sur les dirigeants en gros dans les
entreprises maintenant il ya un certain
nombre d'outils qui sont à disposition
alors les outils je peux vous faire part
d'une petite expérience personnelle les
gens peuvent regarder même quand ils
sont dans des entreprises peuvent
regarder des vidéos des cours en ligne
etc ils le font et ils sont d'autant
plus enclins à le faire que ça pousse à
la base c'est à dire quand il ya à
l'extérieur de l'entreprise des
initiatives comme le manifeste étudiants
pour un réveil écologique ou à
l'intérieur des entreprises des jeunes
qui disent que je trouve que quand même
vous êtes un peu mou du genou j'ai bien
envie d'aller voir ailleurs eh bien ça
pousse les dirigeants à s'intéresser au
problème et quand il commence à
s'intéresser au problème un des trucs
qui font parce que tous ne sont pas
complètement idiot c'est de chercher à
se former sur le sujet de certains sont
idiots certains font de l'année washing
d'autres non voilà dans les cas les
outils pour ça les coûts en ligne il ya
la fraîcheur du climat qui est un truc
qui marche assez bien dans le monde dans
le monde de l'entreprise
il yad'autres d'autres outils qui
peuvent être mises et en ce qui concerne
les jeunes ben en fait là on parle du
système éducatif donc on faire ce qu'on
a dit déjà plusieurs fois sur le fait
que dans les universités alors c'est
plus facile de commencer par
l'enseignement supérieur parce que c'est
des endroits dans lesquels l'auteur une
autonomie sur les programmes donc ça
peut se gérer au niveau des
établissements alors que au niveau du
lycée et du collège ça se gère au niveau
de l'éducation nationale c'est beaucoup
plus lourd c'est beaucoup plus inerte il
n'empêche que certains enseignants
peuvent quand même prendre des
initiatives dans le cadre du programme
ils le font et là dans les initiatives
qui peuvent être utiles c'est mettre à
disposition de ceux qui veulent avancer
du matériel pédagogique ou des contenus
qui peuvent la facilité la ville en
cauchies project on avance modestement
dans cette direction
mais c'est clair qu'il ya plus de boulot
que celui qu'on est capables de battre
il n'y a pas de martingale
malheureusement c'est à dire qu'à cette
question qui est comment on fait bien on
fait qu' il faut multiplier les
initiatives et enfin la dernière
question la jeune femme qui demandait
quelle action moi j'ai envie de dire
tant que vous avez le luxe d'être dans
le système éducatif l'action prioritaire
pour vous c'est de comprendre ce qui se
passait de vous former n'essayez pas
d'agir trop tôt vous vous risquez de
basculer dans des malentendus et 2 et
2,2 de croire trop tôt que vous avez
compris là où il fallait taper donc
profiter vraiment vous savez une vie
celle ont plusieurs décennies même dans
le monde troublé quand vous annoncez
vous n'êtes pas à six mois près donc
vraiment je sais que quand on est jeune
on est impatient mais prenez le temps
vraiment l'action prioritaire qu'il faut
faire tant que vous êtes ici c'est
prenez le temps de bien poser les bases
du problème et prenez le temps de bien
comprendre ce qu'il a à faire et de bien
vous organiser pour le faire voilà je
vous assure que le
sait vraiment ce à votre priorité
ouais moi j'ajoute à un codicille alors
pour ce qui est du scolaire prenez le
temps etc
maintenant je m'adresse en particulier à
celles et ceux
[Musique]
qui commencent à regarder peut-être en
fasse l'écho anxiété qu'ils ressentent
engagez vous aussi
engagez-vous parce que c'est en étant
ensemble
dans les combats pour pour changer les
choses
que l'on
que l'on la dépasse qu'on la regarde
ensemble qu'on la partage et qu'on en
fait pas simplement quelque chose qui
nous assomme et qui nous terrorise mais
qu'on en fait une puissance d'agir pour
changer les choses
et ce sera le mot de la fin un grand
merci aux deux intervenants
et donc encore une fois un grand merci à
toute l'équipe de la paix vous l'avez
annoncé même bateau mais demain nous
recevrons amélie de montchalin ministre
de la transformation public dans ce même
amphithéâtre donc vous pouvez encore
vous inscrire il reste quelques places
pour poser toutes vos questions
[Applaudissements]